a world that will also be involved in
improving the qualifications of a teacher of the
Russian language
[music]
consideration of the main international
regional problems confirmed their
broad coincidence of our approaches to the
need to democratize
international relations, the need to
eliminate elements of injustice
that,
on the initiative of the
collective West, thanks to the
United States, are being forced into the
world
[music  ]
Russia Burundi consistently advocates
respect for the principles of the UN Charter in
their entirety in all their interrelationships,
first of all the principle of sovereign
equality of states which are grossly and
daily trampled upon by the United
States by their allies. We
greatly appreciate our close coordination in the
organization of exchange Nations which will be
continued.
We have confirmed our support
reforming the UN Security Council
by eliminating the problems associated with the
underrepresentation of the countries of the
global south, countries of Africa, Asia,
Latin America,
we spoke in detail about the challenges
that face the need to
overcome the
ongoing crises on the African
Continent
Burundi play an active role in
promoting peacekeeping initiatives
Peacekeepers are actively working  in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo in the
Central African Republic in
Sudan
and, of course,
Burundi's chairmanship
this year of the East African
Community deserves the kindest and highest marks.
Well,
we are in solidarity with the principle that
Mr. Minister just expressed,
I mean African problems,
African solutions,
we consistently support this
approach  and we will continue to be guided
by it When considering certain
crisis situations on the continent in the
Security Council,
we discussed the progress of preparations for the second
Russian Africa summit, which will take place
in a couple of months in St. Petersburg, we
will be very glad to receive there a high
delegation of this country
from international issues, as
the Lord mentioned  Minister We, of course, discussed
what is happening around Ukraine,
we highly appreciate the balanced
balanced position of Burundi, we appreciate a
good understanding of the reasons that
underlie what is happening
in the
West’s use of the Kiev regime
to
create threats to Russian security
directly on our borders and to
destroy the legitimate rights of people who
want to remain involved in the Russian
language to Russian culture,
this situation is only one of the
manifestations of the course that the West
is pursuing to ensure its
dominance on
all continents in all regions of
the world;
therefore, conflicts of this kind cannot be
considered in isolation from the general
geopolitical situation in isolation from the
intentions that the West harbors  in
relation to almost any state that
in one way or another conducts independently.
So, there are a lot of problems in the world,
this requires further
improvement of our interaction,
which we agreed on today And which we
will report to the President of the Republic of Burundi
in a couple of hours Thank you
[music]
and In addition, the
destruction of
our  American partners Moreover,
everything that is happening is
becoming genocidal
in great detail today they talked about this,
there is no doubt that the Kiev regime has
long switched to an openly
terrorist method of
terrorists, for this they use the
weapons that the West pumps up
this regime and
subsequently the West’s statement that the
supplied weapons should not be
used  against the territory of the
Russian Federation from another lie
Well, as for the
threats that are being made against the Russians,
we also told our friends today
how we regard this situation,
threats to kill Russians were made by
many official representatives of the
Kiev regime, including the Secretary of the
Security Council, including the adviser to
the head of the Zelensky administration, including
a few words from Ukraine abroad, the
administration has
now, as you know,
opened up on this topic and one of the
American senators is
very simple because the West insists
that there is no other basis for resolving the
Ukrainian situation other than Zelensky’s
notorious peace formula, and
at the same time Zelensky’s team is threatening
to liberate, as they put it, Crimea and
eastern regions of Ukraine start Killing
all Russians and destroying everything
Russian there; the conclusion is very simple. The West
directly supports
such an age-related
development of a qualitatively new development of the situation when the
West first
became a direct participant in the war
that was unleashed against the Russian
Federation. Now it also calls for
genocide,
you know, it’s always better to know the truth about
Who is up to what in relation to you? We have already found out this
truth quite a long time ago
and we will proceed from the fact that
the West takes exactly this position
and we understand that against this background the ideas
that the countries of the global
majority, including African
countries, express about what they would like  to
contribute to the search for some ways to
overcome this situation, they
speak out sincerely based on the
desire to help in some way
and we appreciate this attitude, but it is
necessary to consider all these ideas of the initiative in the context of the
geopolitical confrontation
that was started by the West against the
Russian Federation and at the same time against
China as it was recently proclaimed in the G7 documents
and it depends
Okay